make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob
and we are picking up with a new
injustice comic this literally got
dropped out of nowhere and it's the
craziest thing right we did a video
previously we were talking about tom
taylor doing a new injustice because all
we had
was like tom taylor tweeting the letter
i and just the words i think it could
have been different and i was like
everybody was just like what in the
world is going on like are we getting a
new injustice
apparently we are right this is
injustice year zero right so this takes
place before
all the other injustice comics which
really kind of makes sense you know
injustice two i guess
not really year two but in justice one
and justice two it takes place before
all of that stuff
and it literally kicks off with what tom
taylor tweeted right batman saying i
think things could have been different
and he basically says
if they were still here right to guide
us to inspire us to remind us of what we
stood for to
and he kind of goes on the speech right
what he's talking about here is the
justice society of america the jsa
is now in the you know injustice series
and this is really
really cool because he kind of comments
and says you know that they are there to
like remind the superheroes that tyranny
often starts with the words they want to
hear now as you kind of go through this
right as we look through this it's
important to understand what the jsa
stands for
and which version of the jsa tom
taylor's talking about they're kind of
three versions of the jsa team one of
which is not really the jsa
at least according to dc fans and i'm
inclined to agree with the most hardcore
fans and the jsa when it originally
existed
in in dc comics was a world war ii team
right in in the sense of like the
publication date right so here in the
real world the jsa was basically
published during the era of world war ii
we didn't really
know that it was the jsa i mean i guess
we did and so far it was all american
and national allied coming together to
form a single team but they were
basically heroes who fought you know
during the
during the era of world war ii now once
you got into the creation of the
multiverse right you go into the silver
age you go into dc showcase number four
in 1956
the introduction of barry allen what dc
did with the flash of two worlds in 1961
is
because of the fact that people like jay
garrick and alan scott were just gone
and they were replaced by new iterations
and there was no real explanation as to
you know what the difference was or
where it was that jay garrick and alan
scott went to
and why they were replaced with barry
allen and hal jordan respectively what
you ended up getting here was the
creation of the multiverse and the the
creation of earth 2 and what earth 2
gave us was a jsa team
basically saying like the characters you
read in the 1940s that was earth 2.
and we basically switched universes in
1956 with dc showcase number four we
just didn't tell you that's more or less
what dc did right it wasn't really in in
so far as
a direct statement but that's more or
less what happened now the version of
the jsa that tom taylor's using here
is the jsa team that we saw return in
the 1990s and the reason why was because
after the events of crisis on infinite
earth there was no multiverse right so
there was no earth 2 for the jsa to hail
from they simply just didn't exist
and so you got a couple stories here and
there where like the jsa were kind of
time displaced different things like
that but the long and short is that once
the jsa returned and we got an ex
an explanation of who they were what we
were basically told is that the jsa were
superheroes during world war
ii and that they had long since retired
by the time batman superman wonder woman
by the time those characters came along
now the third version of the jsa came
during the new 52 and while the
the earth 2 line of comics were really
good especially the first issue the jsa
in terms of
as it existed before the events of new
52 was
totally different from the version that
existed after the new 52 and a lot of
fans rejected that right they they liked
the story but they rejected the
characters in terms of who they were how
they gained their powers people wanted
to see a return of the original justice
society of america
and that's what we got during doomsday
clock we got the return of the classic
jsa
albeit you know just by a different
means more or less but this is kind of
cool because this is what they're
talking about here right they're talking
about the idea of the jsa they're
talking about the return of these old
school superheroes that basically kind
of set this standard on what it meant to
be a hero because while superman is the
most iconic the jsa are the ones that
inspired superman to become
superman you know in addition to the
kents but kind of laid that foundation
for here's what it means to be a hero a
person with powers and to do good in the
world and so what this does is it
switches over to about a year before
this story starts with a guy named mr
chavard right and this guy is basically
up for parole now the idea is that he
committed a series of heinous crimes and
despite the fact that he's basically ill
and he's essentially dying
the parole board basically states that
he has not finished serving his debt to
society right and so he's end up you
know
he basically goes back to his cell to
finish out whatever his prison sentence
seems to be which appears to be life in
prison
and so in response to this he encounters
a cell mate or at least another prisoner
named brick and asks to send off a
letter and when rick's like okay what am
i offering in this instance like what am
i what am i selling here the response of
shavard is
absolute power right the power to
control a god and this is when we switch
over to superman and that kind of seems
to be what he's talking about right the
ability to control superman in his
entirety now what we end up doing is of
course picking up with the goons of
black mask who are kind of doing their
thing in gotham and there's not a whole
lot doing here right it's just a normal
day for the for the batman team
the cool thing is it's good to see tim
drake is back like tim drake died
within like the first like the first
year of injustice but
the funny thing is superman's here to
basically check with batman and to make
sure he's actually going to go
right to whatever this event is and
initially batman you know suit man's
like the reason i thought you were going
to come here is because you were going
to look for a reason to stay in gotham
city and basically like batman's like
yeah man because like the black goons or
the the black masculines are terrorizing
the city so like you know i've i've got
to stay here man
and tim drake being tim drake that he is
is like no man
you can go like we we got this thing
here of batman
you're good bruce wayne and so of course
it kind of pisses off bruce a little bit
but we end up switching over to the
justice league watchtower and finding
out that it's like a celebration party
for the jsa i don't know why batman
wouldn't want to go to this
like why would batman not want to go to
like a celebration of the jsa
this is the jsa in all of its glory
right hawkman hot girl the spectre
doctor fate who's actually somebody new
it's basically uh enza kramer or at
least a replacement outside of uh the
existing
dr fate you got sandman you've got
liberty bell she's old school
uh you've got the flash jay garrick this
is basically just a bunch of old school
characters now something to note here is
none of them are young
which is a great play by tom taylor to
kind of show how old these guys are in
the sense that they've been around
since the 1940s right since world war ii
right black canaries an old woman all
kinds of cool stuff uh but
it's it's basically like the the justice
league giving a toast
saying like we are here to honor the
individuals who came
first and that's what makes the jsa so
important
for for dc fans right that's why dc fans
looked to the jsa
as being such an important team they
laid the groundwork for everything that
would become
the justice league of america the flash
barry allen green lantern hal jordan
the modern day black canary uh you know
superman batman all these characters
take their cues from the jsa but what
you also end up getting here
is is a really cool scenario where
wildcat kind of gives batman a little
bit of a hard time
and then the two of them actually engage
in a fist fight kind of a sparring
session of sorts where you end up having
these kind of rules laid down right
batman can't use anything but it's fists
right and even ted grant's kind of like
you know you can't use any trained
attack bats and batman's like what are
you talking about he's like i don't keep
up with you man i don't know what you
have
right you're batman you have whatever
you need at any point in time right so
it's kind of a little bit of bickering
going on there but batman launches an
attack and hits ted grant the nerve so
then ted grant responds
by backhanding batman and knocking him
to the ground in that instance
barry allen takes off goes and grabs jay
garrick and says hey man like bring
popcorn
batman's getting knocked down so jay
garrick and flash get back there right
as batman gets hit and they're just kind
of watching this whole thing go down
they're watching batman
and and wildcat fight each other and
ultimately of course you know with
batman being knocked down i guess that
kind of means that that wildcats the
victor and it's kind of a funny thing
right you just see like
jay garrick and barry allen just
smashing popcorn watching batman get
beat up of course spectre
ends up taking off and the party more or
less just kind of begins to wind down
from there right batman confronts jay
garrick and barry allen was like i know
you guys were eating popcorn and then
basically ends up you know ends up on
his way out but of course
before that he's basically stopped by
superman right now at this point we
switch back over to the prison
with mr chaver and this guy you know
basically you have like this massive
prison break happening
a guard running for his life this guy
gets shot up only for us to basically
end up encountering the joker
right the joker's basically broken in
here to rescue this guy whose first name
is andre right that's what we're gonna
call him from now on we're gonna call
him andre but the joker was the one who
answered this call right that if this
guy sent out this sos basically saying
anybody who can get me out of here will
get the power to control a god the joker
answers the call and so what we end up
doing here
is switching over to superman and batman
having this conversation
and it's kind of funny because initially
batman's not overly in favor of kind of
like
looking at things from the from the
watchtower right like being in the
watchtower being so distant from earth
but the response to superman is it's a
good idea and the reason why is because
when it comes to them as superheroes
they don't exist to protect any
individual city even though they operate
out of those cities right batman
operates out of gotham superman operates
out of
out of metropolis like that's basically
how these things work but for superman
they're protectors of the world first
and foremost right they're just kind of
holding off and operating in a
particular area at some point along the
line and what he basically says is
this is awesome right because you've got
generations of heroes you got the first
black canary you got the second black
canary right like the first flash the
second flash and so so with that being
the case like you know you've got hal
jordan you've got alan scott you got
generations of heroes and the idea here
is that this is designed to kind of
you know one allow them to look at the
world without any kind of borders but
then also sort of ask the question like
what comes next right that's what
superman's been asking about what comes
next he starts talking about legacy you
know superman basically kind of talks to
batman and says you already have a
legacy you know you mentored barbara
gordon and
cassandra kane you raised dick grayson i
think i referred to dick grayson as tim
earlier in the story now that i think
about it uh okay if i did that was dick
grayson that was not tim drake but
you know the response to batman is well
you know the jury's still out on damien
wayne right you know the jury's still
out on him you know
at the end of the day superman's like no
like he's your son man he's a good kid
he's just pissed off of the world and
when batman says so with jason uh the
response of of superman is yeah but like
damien's not jason todd damien's your
biological son this is a wholly
different set of events right you have
the ability to change this kid's life in
a way that you couldn't do with jason
todd damien wayne is the biological son
of bruce they will have
a a kind of bond that none of the other
members of the bat family will ever have
and we saw that play out
in the other injustice comics right we
know how that works and so it's one of
these things where where batman starts
talking to superman and asking have you
talked to lois about the idea of having
kids right are you guys wanting to do
that and the response of superman is
probably one of the best responses ever
the response to superman is yeah but
it's difficult we both want the same
thing but there's a fear out there
the world is a scary place and anybody
who's who's a responsible human being
and thinking about having kids
understands that fear that the world can
be a scary place more so than that this
child that you create is going to go out
into the world and you
as you know your involvement in that
child's life is going to have a
huge impact on not only how they see the
world but how they see themselves i mean
yes it's the role of a child to take the
teachings of their parents to listen to
them to incorporate them into their
mindset but then they graduate out into
the greater tribe they make friends
those friends have impact on their lives
the experiences that they have have
impact on their lives yes that's true
but at the end of the day they always
come home
and the relationship between a child and
a parent is one of the most
one of the most important relationships
that any individual will ever have and
how that relationship
forms is based on how that parent treats
that child and how that parent
has that child view the world right and
so there's a huge amount of fear there
and this is cool
because it humanizes superman and i know
that's a cliche statement to make but it
does
right it really really really does
because superman is not a human
but at the end of the day superman is a
person that understands what it means to
have kids it's the universal factor of
life
borrowing any kind of alien race out
there that doesn't view children in the
same way that any sort of human would do
and instead views them as just kind of
like a means to an end or they're like a
warrior race whatever the case is
every parent cares about their child
right where at least they should care
about their child and so what superman
feels here is universal across the board
even batman feels that whether he's
willing to admit it or not and so you
end up having amazing man will everett
of course walking in here alongside
alongside alan scott and superman's like
well we're talking about legacies right
and batman's like well superman doesn't
think he has one and they're like really
you're superman dude like you may not
have noticed but like
you've inspired your entire generation
and the next generation which is true
right like the jsa inspired superman and
the various superheroes to be the
superheroes they are superman inspired
everybody else right like he's
literally the superhero and so it's kind
of like your legacy is
is solidified but it's not really that
that he's talking about it's the legacy
he leaves behind insofar as like a child
and that kind of a thing right so then
we pick up of course with andre we pick
up with the joker andre made the dumbest
decision he possibly could
he basically led the joker and harley
quinn to like where his family lives
right because andre's idea is to go and
talk to like his grandson to have a
conversation with him to say hey look
the one thing that i want to say here is
that i'm sorry
you know for for everything that
happened we don't really know what it is
it took place but basically saying like
i'm sorry and then his grandson's like
is that the joker and the joker's like
yeah man you know and so his grandson's
like dude you show up out of nowhere in
the middle of the night
to apologize and you bring a homicidal
maniac to my home and the joker's like
yeah man this is probably not a good
idea andre
like you didn't really think this out
did you
[Laughter]
so it's kind of like andre you're an
idiot right like like you need to think
a little bit more about what you do
and so it's kind of nuts because of
course this leads to to batman you know
kind of going forward and doing his
thing and then of course arriving at
blackgate penitentiary where andre was
previously being held
uh where the joker had of course broken
him out and of course you got nightwing
there you've got huntress there the two
of them are kind of talking you know
going over the crime scene together so
on and so forth and they more or less
give batman the details that they were
there three minutes and
basically almost four minutes after the
alarm was sounded and by then the joker
was already gone with andre and it's
kind of nuts
because in their mind it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense right that
like the joker comes he breaks into a to
a prison and then frees one man and
batman's kinda like this doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense this is a
little
weird here and so when he talks to
commissioner gordon commissioner gordon
basically tells him of course it's andre
chavard he's 86 years old and where
batman gives off the indication that he
knows who he is
and and the responsible board is yeah
man he's been serving a sentence for or
at least he's been here
serving 55 years of his sentence he was
just denied parole and and the response
of
of huntress is yeah like he's he's dying
that's why the parole board rejected his
parole on compassionate grounds
and so of course you switch back to
andre and we'll i'm kind of holding off
okay we'll do a quick explanation of
andre right there's not a whole lot
going there andre was introduced in dc
comics in detective comics number 64
back in 1942 as best as i can surmise he
came off the popularity of uh of dick
grayson
being introduced in detective comics as
robin as well as bucky barnes and
captain america
comics from uh from what at the time was
timely publications
but he was part of a group called the
boy commandos there's not a whole lot
doing with him right he was just kind of
there for a little while and he had a
couple roles here and there but he's by
no means anybody of significance
it may be one of these things where tom
taylor's introducing him and then going
to like
bring a whole new backstory or whole new
elements of his backstory that we didn't
know about before but the important
thing here is we pick up with andre with
joker and harley quinn and basically
joker's saying okay
i've done what i've done for you now
it's time for you to do for me right so
show me how to how to gain the power of
a god and the response of andre is no
i'm not going to show you that right i'm
86 years old i'm i'm an old man i'm dead
anyway i don't i have nothing
there's there's nothing for me to lose
and the response of the joker is but you
just showed me where your family lives
so let me go back and let me help you
understand why it's a bad idea for you
to double cross me and starts cutting
off the fingers of his grandson right
like the most joker thing that a person
could do and so of course this leads to
andre basically panicking and saying
okay like i'll tell you everything you
want to know
i'll tell you everything that you could
want to know here uh and so he kind of
breaks down
and and tells this story right and what
we find out is that during the
during the age of or during the time of
world war ii the what you ended up
having here was basically carter hall
and chiara hall right hawkman and
hawkgirl and of course as we know
they're immortal right they were cursed
ages and ages and ages ago that they
would basically you know every time they
died they'd be reborn in new bodies they
would find each other they would live a
life and then they would die again but
it's one of these things where they know
about this they know they're immortal
and they'll always be reborn so they're
not really afraid of death but in 1942
they were effectively grave robbers and
they end up kind of digging and of
course shaira falls into a giant hole
and this is hey guys
you got to get down here and that's when
she finds this tomb with a symbol what
looks like a symbol of dr fate but it's
upside down
and so that leads to them just kind of
investigating it and saying like we
should probably open this and then you
know when carter hall's like i mean do
you think we should crack this thing
open the response to shira is yeah
of course we should you know now it's
kind of a funny thing because this is
referred to as
the queen's tomb we can kind of
interpret this in a couple different
ways that carter hall and chiara have
been
excavating the tomb of a queen or we can
say this is the queen of nabi the person
that gave kent nelson his powers the guy
known as dr fate right and the fact that
it looks like the symbol of dr
fate albeit upside down kind of lends
credence to the fact that it's the
the queen of of of naboo now again we
don't know if that's entirely true we
don't fully know what's going on here
but what we do know is that where no
normal person could have opened this
open this cell because of the fact or at
least open this door because of the fact
that this is shira and hawkman
they were able to pry it open right and
of course they find this person
basically
kind of nailed to the wall and then of
course they find this amulet around
their neck
and as soon as shayera picks it up right
she immediately you know she puts on
this helmet and then she she immediately
like grabs this amulet and is just kind
of bestowed with like all these
different voices and just kind of saying
things like i know what they want me to
do
and then of course she immediately
changes into a costume because of the
amulet and then flies out into
the battle of alamein during world war
ii and then just starts wreaking
absolute havoc of course this leads to
carter hall intervening the two of them
getting into a conflict of sorts and
then her basically overpowering carter
hall and carter hall more or less being
completely and totally incapacitated and
then once she realizes that she's more
or less killed him that she kind of
begins to to snap back to herself to a
degree once she returns back to her
normal self she takes the amulet off and
then carter hall of course ends up dying
right her realizing that she's basically
the one that killed him we also end up
finding out that this
this is basically the amulet of apophis
right that's what this amulet is
now i've been kind of researching around
and looking around
i don't know who apophis is in dc comics
and i don't even know if they exist
right so if one of you all know
teach me educate me down in the comments
section
because i haven't been able to find
anything on that character but with that
that amy like basically being left there
by by shearer when she basically whisks
away with carter hall uh the australian
and british expeditionary forces come
across the aftermath and when they do
a guy named dirk strasser ends up
picking up the amulet and then basically
is taken over by the amulet's power and
what seems to be happening here is the
amulet
wants to get to a particular destination
right now in a lot of ways it looks like
strasser is just kind of acting of his
own accord right so maybe he's just the
one who realizes he has a power in his
possession
and he's just doing what he wants with
it either way we'll have to wait for the
next issue to find out what it is with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you